surprise Monster Hunter it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
y'all great to have you back this is
going to be a breakdown of a very
reflective episode 4 of Monarch Legacy
of monsters that teases a big connection
to Godzilla versus Kong while also
diving into the characters of May and
canaro how they met and a little more
about what matters the most to them in
this world all while everybody tries not
to freeze to death while running from a
giant mole monster a mole monster that
wants to suck them off this plane of
existence lots to talk about so let's
get into it the episode starts with an
introduction of a new character on the
scene Monarch research agent Barnes
played by Jess elto who has starred in
other hit sci-fi shows such as the
expanse and is probably most famously
known for her role as the quickly
liquefied Robin Ward on the hit Amazon
TV show the boys when we first meet
Barnes she's chilling on a beach in Utah
right outside of Monarch trailer Outpost
47 in the modern day Day of 2015
listening to the 1992 hit Baby Got Back
by Sir mixalot and reading a copy of
Neuromancer which is a 1984 sci-fi novel
by William Gibson Barn seems to be a bit
of a voracious reader of Science in
historical fiction as the mini library
in her Monarch research trailer also
includes 2015's Armada by Ernest Klein
2000's Revelation Space by Alistair
Reynolds 1974's the mo in God's eye by
Larry Nan and Jerry pornel 2001's
Kingdom of cages by Sarah zettle 2001's
time Quake by Kirk vaget 2002's ancient
encounters kenowick man and the first
Americans by James C Chatters 2010 zero
history by William Gibson again 1982's
the Cyborg and the sorcerers by lawence
watt Evans 2003's Quicksilver and 1994's
interface by Neil Stevenson so needless
to say Barnes is a big old nerd a big
old nerd who is fueled by Energy Drinks
like most nerds are in real life with
armag gedon being Barn's favorite brand
which is ironic considering that Barn
spends all of her time trying to help
stop monster Armageddon with Monarch
after one of Barnes instruments alerts
Barnes of a global rise in gamma
radiation only found in pulsars from
outer space we learn that Verdugo has
the role of assistant director of
Monarch essentially making her the vice
president of the whole secret shindig
the show then brings us on a journey
back in time to Tokyo 2014 a year before
the present day events of the show we
meet up with a 2 14 kentaro and learn
that he is an artist who is about to
open his first ever art show which
should be exciting but yet he's still
struggling with a deep sense of
unhappiness before what should be one of
the most exciting moments of his career
in large part because he had this
immense anxiety around his Art Exhibit
not being good enough to further his art
career and make his father proud because
his father believed in his artistic
abilities so damn much but another major
reason why I believe canaro is deeply
avoidant of his own exhibit is that he
didn't didn't really feel like that
exhibit was a true expression of his
passions as an artist and we see this
shown best when canaro and May's first
date brings the two on over to Cano's
art field Department later on with all
the art in his apartment being
reflective of the type of art that
canaro actually likes to create canaro
seems to be a big fan of capturing faces
in his art but unlike the human faces
that light up his exhibit the faces that
canaro actually likes to draw come in
the form of various cultural m masks of
Japan in particular the Japanese Oni
mask which have been used in traditional
Japanese ceremonies in the hopes that
these creepy ass faces of these masks
will be enough to scare off evil spirits
and monsters and bring about peace and
protection for the wearer which I
thought was super symbolically fitting
for the son of a man who spent his
entire life researching how to protect
Humanity from Monsters with Monarch
while simultaneously putting on a fake
mask for both of his families in order
to protect them and a lot of Japanese
Samurai were demon themed mask into
battle in order to strike fear into
their enemies as well which is why we
can see drawings of such Samurai on
Cano's wall and also why canaro likes to
wear slippers designed with black and
white Samurai at home this all being
said through his art we can definitely
see canaro strong affinity for wanting
to defend other people I mean hell the
very first time we're introduced to
karo's artwork in May's apartment in an
earlier episode we can see that canaro
willingly chose to depict an image of a
Sci-Fi soldier holding a big ass gun
facing to fight a giant spider monster
so it definitely feels like Koshi
randa's protective nature imprinted onto
his son which makes sense considering
how Hiroshi basically left canaro alone
with his mom to be the man of the house
for the majority of his life so that was
basically the type of role that canaro
was forced into from an early age due to
his father's Monarch Monster hunting but
anyways though demon type masks seem to
dominate karo's room we can also see a
couple of Japanese masks of smiling
women called an okame mask which have
been traditionally worn by women to
bring about good luck good health and
joy into their lives but despite his
exhibit not being truly reflective of
himself as a Creator Cano's artistic
fascination with faces and masks led him
to create what his exhibit describes as
an exploration of parallels and
interiors that invites the viewers to
challenge their assumptions about
identity which is a detail I found to be
the most interesting because we see that
reflected within the cinematography of
the show itself a show about two
separate families spinning across two
different eras deeply rooted within the
idea of parallels Symmetry and dualities
much like we can see represented in the
intro theme animation of this show and
with the show's various relationships
like the relationship between canaro and
May canaro and Kate Bill Randa and Lee
Shaw KO and Kate like the show is all
about parallels man throughout this
episode and series as a whole canaro
learns to challenge his own assumption
about the identity of his mysterious
father and how much Cano's own deep
design desire to make his father proud
blinded canaro from seeing just how
loved he's always been by both of his
parents just by being who he is and this
theme of faces continues with the
brilliant cinematography of May and
Cano's first meeting and date because
after canaro tries to photograph his
event poster and accidentally takes a
photograph of May the two start flirting
in front of the face exhibit poster that
hangs on this wall with a giant red
streak on it but what's interesting
about this becomes clear when we check
out just how this red streak is framed
in relation to May and canaro in this
scene with the red streak symbolically
shooting from May's face all the way to
karo's heart to reflect how may herself
was seeking to challenge her own
assumptions about karo's identity by
getting a closer look at his inner heart
after she assumed that he was just some
pretentious fancy dude just by the
haircut that he was forced to get and
when canaro and may are having their
date at the bar check out this circular
white Spotlight in the back of the frame
as the two start to get to know each
other better they slowly inch closer
together within the bubble of this light
but it's only when this Center circular
Spotlight transitions to the centered
circular window of karo's apartment that
the two finally feel connected enough
for their two faces to come together for
a kiss these two circles captured canaro
and May's faces just like Cano's whole
artistic career is about capturing faces
in general which I thought was a very
nice symbolic touch but another nice
touch that I notic is that when they
kiss canaro is purposely placed on the
side of the frame with his art desk on
it while May is placed on the side of
the frame with Cano's computer
reflecting their specific areas of
expertise but the only reason why canaro
even got that kiss in the first place is
because my boy whipped out that just
trust me move from Aladdin when he held
his hand out to May on their way to that
secret bar I tried that flirtation
technique one time and was immediately
pepper sprayed in the face causing me to
cry in the fetal position at my local
Subway for about 30 to 45 minutes so
needless to say your mileage may vary on
that one but anyways after the kiss
canaro leaves while May gets another
call from what appears to be her sister
Lyra who she brings up to Kate while she
fights off her hypothermia seeing as the
show is heavily themed around dualities
and this collar seems to be deeply
attached the movements of her sister I
would not be surprised to learn later on
that Lyra and may were actually
identical twins with very different
personalities because that would just
fit in with the overall theme but only
time will tell on that one but it
definitely seems like we're going to run
into Lyra soon at some point in this
series but the most interesting parts of
this episode for me of course come in
the form of radiation I'm a big fan of
radiation both in the MCU and this
universe both when Barnes is able to
present her radiation findings to
assistant director Verdugo and the team
at Monarch and when the radiation of the
region caused Shaw Kate and may to
accidentally walk around aimlessly in
circles because I think these two things
are deeply connected when Barnes is
updating Monarch we learn that these
spikes in gamma radiation were sharply
correlated with the imminent emergence
of a monster just like it did for
Godzilla during his initial gday
appearance I believe that this show is
deeply implying that the mysterious blue
beam of light that Shaw May and Kate
were following is radiation from the
same mysterious blue energy source that
flows abundantly inside of the hollow
Earth and is apparently the source of
life for all of the Titans that come
from the hollow Earth through one of the
many Stargate style wormholes that exist
within the planet itself and since this
show is set a full n years before the
events of Godzilla versus Kong where the
evil Company Apex cybernetics tries to
repurpose that Hollow Earth energy to
power their Mecca Godzilla I have a
feeling that The Narrative of Monarch
Legacy of monsters is going to show us
exactly how entities like monarch and
Apex first learned about these Wormhole
tunnels to the hollow Earth and the
potential power emanating from the
center of the planet as team Kong and
Godzilla versus Kong actually head to
another cold region of Antarctica in
order to access another one of these
tunnels in that movie and since these
radioactive Wormhole tunnels allow for
quick transport across thousands of
miles in an instant this would also
serve to explain why the gang got all
turned around in the snow something
about that radiation seems to be
manipulating SpaceTime and even possibly
gravity to such a degree that it can
actually teleport people around without
them knowing giving credence to Young
Bill randa's teleportation theory that
he threw at General pocket in a previous
episode about how Godzilla is able to
move around the planet so easily a
theory that I brought up in my my last
video on Monarch Legacy of monsters a
video that you should check out here and
this radiation might actually end up
contributing to why leaw is able to be
so spry for a 90s something year old guy
as he has been exposed to Kaiju
radiation pretty much his entire career
so maybe this Ultra powerful Kaiju
energy source inside of the Hidden Earth
could actually hold the secrets to human
immortality like I feel like that would
actually make a really interesting plot
point for a future Godzilla or Kong
movie in the future in my opinion but
anyways when Tim gets to talk to the
Monarch team about Bar's presentation he
again tries to underscore the importance
of Bill randa's files and how they could
potentially prevent another monster
attack but I noticed as soon as he said
that particular thing assistant director
verduga appears to have a somewhat
solemn look on her face implying to me
that she may have lost someone close to
her in a Kaiju attack herself but of
course the episode ends with canaro
eventually finding one of his father's
camps and founding for a rescue from the
very people that they were running from
this entire time but I actually super
excited for this next episode because I
have got to know just what the hell
happened between Hiroshi and Lee Shaw
that is motivating Lee to try to find
hiroshi's ass because I feel like it's
more than Shaw's ties to KO and Bill
Randa that is pushing Lee to risk his
life like this like Shaw definitely
knows a lot more than he's letting on
which is why may doesn't trust his ass
fully but anyways that is it for this
breakdown of Monarch Legacy of monsters
let us know what you guys think of the
show in the comment section below thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at M rainment on
Twitter or Instagram or wherever I am on
the internet but most importantly don't
forget to follow heavy spoilers here on
YouTube because we always got some
really interesting stuff for you guys
yes thanks again for watching you guys
are amazing and I'll see you guys next
time goodbye